darby allen perhaps taking out a
competition for good
sammy says i'm crazy
absolutely amazing that's what the
doctor is in
my god he's going to try to contract him
on the
oh power bomb on the table
the times keepers table and on the ring
bill
[Applause]
yeah there's the blood oh
and look at this the power bomb on the
on the ring bell the back of moxley's
head
striking the steel of the bell
and a torrent of blood leaking from john
moxley's
right side
[Applause]
i mean this is this is dangerous yes
exactly yeah
right now they're they're 15 feet in the
air maybe cameraman just took a fall
yeah 10 feet in the air
oh my god
hardy with a powerful right hand
knocking sammy cavara through the stage
now moxley thinking paradigm shift oh my
god
marxley oh they're going to need some
medical attention now
there's a doctor right there johnny on
the spot but can he even get down there
with that broken toe oh here you go he's
just stop it good lord
geez he's sadistic martin anderson can't
believe what he's seen
[Applause]
he's got him on the bar oh god we've
how many movies do we see this hand in
westerns with john wayne
just running him through everything
it looks us look i see now the quiet man
and now darby allen
has firm control and that's going to be
one hell of a ride
oh my god harvey is thinking about this
my god ladies and gentlemen where he is
darby on top of the ladder oh my god he
went to crush kassarian but instead came
down on that knee
more now oh maybe the nose now
oh look out moxley paradigm shift
attempt
nope oh kingston almighty
to the bare skin those thumbtacks
just penetrated throughout the body
arms the shoulder matt hardy's almost
orgasmic
omega what are we doing here with sami
oh no
oh god heaven good lord the one winged
angel